Speaker 1: we've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
This is really funny. This is a joke voicemail,
but it's nicely done. Yesterday, we talked on the
show about the oratory skills of former President
Barack Obama in the context of campaigning for
tech, a Virginia gubernatorial candidate,
Terry McAuliffe. Here's a funny caller who
says now Obama wasn't that great of a
speaker at these events. Take a look.
Speaker 7: Hi, David. I really don't agree with
your assessment of Barack Obama as a great orator.
He didn't fart. He didn't talk about toilet
belittled the Holocaust. I really think
Rudy Giuliani, Trump and Taylor
Greene are much better orators, right?
Speaker 1: No, it is true. There was
no discussion at all of plumbing.
Speaker 2: We're looking very strongly at sinks
and showers, elements of bathrooms. People are
flushing toilets 10 times. 15.
Speaker 1: OK, that last one
still gets me. No, it is true. As far as we know,
Barack Obama had no flatulence events like Rudy
Giuliani. He didn't trivialize the Holocaust
like Marjorie Taylor Greene. He didn't talk
about plumbing the way Donald Trump sometimes
does. We're going to be covering these last few
Terry McAuliffe rallies. Joe Biden's going to be
out with him. Maybe Barack Obama will be back out
with him again tonight. In fact, Biden will be
out with McAuliffe, and McAuliffe's opponent,
Glenn Youngkin has a rally. So today we will be
live streaming and I think it's an important race,
Virginia gubernatorial, but very well said by the
caller on today's bonus show. Democrats suing the
Postal Service. Why? We will tell you, does the
IRS really spy on your bank account? This is a new
right wing idea. And is there any truth to it or
is there no truth to it? Are they going too far?
What's what's the truth? We'll talk about it, and
there's more and more pressure in the aftermath of
the Alec Baldwin disaster, where Alec Baldwin
accidentally killed someone on set last week.
More pressure to just not even have real guns on
Hollywood sets at all. We're going to talk about
that on today's bonus show as well. Get instant
access by signing up at Join Packman dot com. We
will see you on the bonus show
Unidentified: in mere moments.